يعد التسلسل الجيني هو المفتاح
للعثور على أي
طفرات متغيرة جديدة من هذا
المكان حيث نحن في ما هو مطلوب
من حيث الحصول على معالجة كاملة
لهذا الأمر بينما نعمل على الحصول على المزيد من الأمريكيين الذين يتم
تطعيمهم
بابي ، فأنت محق ، إنه مفتاح
البحث عن
طفرات فيروسية جديدة ومن المهم جدًا
أن نحصل على هذه الطفرات
بأسرع ما يمكن ، لم
نقم بعمل رائع في هذا
مقارنة ببعض البلدان الأخرى ، دعنا
نلقي نظرة على سبب أهمية
القيام بذلك  هذا التسلسل الجيني ومن ثم
مشاركته في جميع أنحاء العالم
بحيث يمكن أن يكون البحث
دوليًا جيدًا بالطريقة التي يعمل بها هو
أن تأخذ عينة من الفيروس
من أنف شخص ما من شخص
يطمع في 19 ثم تحدد
التسلسل الجيني لذلك  فيروس
الفيروس ثم تنشره على قاعدة بيانات
للمشاركة دوليًا
بحيث يمكن التعرف على المتغيرات الطافرة ،
وهنا ما لا يسير على ما يرام في
الولايات المتحدة ، حيث يبلغ عمر التسلسلات التي يتم نشرها
حوالي 85 يومًا  قديم
نريد أن نعرف ما يحدث الآن أو
أقرب ما يكون الآن قدر
الإمكان ، أه نحن في المرتبة 61 في هذا الوقت نحن
خلف بنجلاديش وسريلانكا وجميع
أنواع البلدان الأخرى
ومن حيث عدد
تسلسلات الفيروسات فقط  عند الحصول على منشور ، نحن في
المرتبة
35 ، وبعبارة أخرى ، نحن لا نفعل
ما يكفي ،
لكن الخشخاش جيم يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إنهم
يعملون على هذا الأمر ، إنهم ينفقون
ملايين الدولارات لزيادة
التسلسل الذي يتم إجراؤه
في المعامل الحكومية الخاصة في
الجامعات وقالوا
إننا  يجب أن نشهد زيادة في
القريب العاجل لجيم الخشخاش